und jetzt das heute schon mal
mit kaiser richter und claus kleber
guten abend air force one ist glücklich
wieder in der luft irgendwo über dem
nordatlantik donald trump vor 3 stunden
aus london abgereist er und die 28
anderen staats und regierungschefs haben
den gipfel zum siebzigsten geburtstag
des nato bündnisses oder skandal und
ohne großen öffentlichen streit
überstanden das war nicht
selbstverständlich
es gab so viele bruchstellen zwischen
den usa und europa der türkei und dem
rest trump um max merkel und accord
trump und merke man kann schon als
erfolg sehen und verkaufen dass die nato
trotzdem noch zusammen ist und sogar in
der lage neue ziele zu erfassen
im at wissen über den siebzigsten
geburtstag des bündnisses der nicht
gefeiert wurde er überstanden und
erledigt ein klares signal und zwar der
einigkeit könnte so aussehen wir bei der
nato stehen für die prinzipien der
liberalen demokratie gegen alle die sie
gefährden terrorismus russland china so
sehen es auch einige hier aber wohl
nicht alle
vielleicht deshalb hat der emanuel makro
so heftig hingelangt die nato hirntod ob
er seine kritik heute morgen nun doch
bereit überhaupt nicht nein ich stehe
dazu ich absolut außerdem haben meine
worte eine debatte angestoßen die
unausweichlich ist man sieht sie ja
gedeihen wir haben so viele themen zu
klären seien vom fußweg zwischen
ausgerechnet da lässt die eigentliche
führungsmacht der nato auf sich warten
und warten
der fehlt da noch und wachten minuten
lang hohe symbolik amerika führt nicht
mehr gibt nicht den takt an weiß
vielleicht selbst nicht wohin die reise
gehen soll
vielleicht deshalb trauen sie sich jetzt
etwas früher fast undenkbar war am
vorabend im buckingham palast lässt dann
die anderen über donald trump weil er
immer zu spät kommen
das stärkste militärbündnis der welt hat
ein führungsvakuum auch deshalb fasst
der gipfel recht sanfte beschlüsse mit
russland will man reden china als
herausforderung studieren
obwohl viele hier über moskaus
provokationen empört sind und über
chinas wachsenden einfluss auch in nato
mitgliedsländern besorgt über
terrorismus habe man halt
meinungsverschiedenheiten aber die
allianz sei doch gestärkt
wir stehen zusammen einer für alle alle
für einen
der artikel 15 beistandspflicht im
bündnis steht eisenach und der der
ebendiese beistandspflicht einst selbst
in frage stellte sieht sich nun als fan
der nato sehr zum erstaunen aller
anderen
ich war jetzt auf drei nato gipfeln
dieser war der beste ganz besonders hier
herrscht ein guter geist viele geben
jetzt richtig viel geld
das stimmt durch trumps druck steigen
die militärausgaben der mitgliedsländer
deutlich aber zur strategischen
neuausrichtung schenkt sich die nato nun
zum geburtstag eine reflexionsgruppe die
aufklären soll
was eigentlich längst klar sein müssen
wir waren uns heute auch einig dass der
terrorismus der größte feind ist
verbunden ja auch zum teil mit
asymmetrischen bedrohung und hier muss
die reflexionsgruppe nach meiner meinung
natürlich einmal befinden welche rolle
sie die nato im kampf gegen den
terrorismus ohne pressekonferenz
verliess donald trump den gipfel und
überließ die bewertung anderen die
bisherige führungsmacht darf sich nicht
wundern dass die auch mal sagen wollen
wo es langgeht in der nato das neue
bedrohungs profil bedeutet nicht einfach
einen rückfall in den kalten krieg so
platt wiederholt sich geschichte wohl
nicht die nato deutet aber in ihrer
abschlusserklärung erstmals eine welt an
in der russland nicht mehr der
hauptgegner ist den platz wird china
beanspruchen und dieser trend ist
deutlich schon heute hat china die
zweithöchsten militärausgaben der welt
heißt es
das stimmt wahrscheinlich aber der
abstand zu den usa ist schon gewaltig
russland und deutschland verschwinden da
im vergleich mit ihren beträgen und die
nationalen zahlen lassen das
entscheidende aus dass die usa unter
anderem die nato dominieren während
chinas militär keine verbündeten hat es
geht aber nicht nur um milliarden und
panzer und schiffe china entwickelt
gerade zum ersten mal in seiner
jahrtausende alten geschichte einen
globalen machtanspruch und das verändert
tatsächlich die welt
ulf röller ist unser korrespondent in
pick wer stärker hat zeigt sie und china
zeigt seine stärke immer häufiger wie
zum siebzigsten jahrestag zur
staatsgründung vor zwei monaten vor den
augen der weltöffentlichkeit lässt das
reich der mitte die militärischen
muskeln spielen
neue waffen für ein neues
selbstbewusstsein
präsident schäfer lässt sich nicht mehr
nur auf die wirtschaftliche kraft des
landes china hat den zweitgrößten
militär haushalt der welt mit rund 250
milliarden dollar im jahr
man will eine militärmacht werden die
auf augenhöhe steht mit den usa und den
usa
dementsprechend dann auch in
verschiedenen komplikationen begegnen
kann und diese spielen sich natürlich
aus sicht der usa vor allen dingen in
zukunft im asiatischen raum selber ab
einer von zehn flugzeugträgern der usa
die uss george washington
noch sind die vereinigten staaten die
weltmacht nummer eins im pazifik aber
das duell mit china hat schon lange
begonnen einen flugzeugträger haben die
chinesen bereits ein zweiter wird
getestet ein dritter ist wohl in planung
aufrüstung für die vorherrschaft china
weltmacht 1b stellt die machtfrage in
der region ein militär es dazu da um zu
kämpfen kampfbereitschaft ist der
maßstab und die fähigkeit zu gewinnen
wenn es gefordert wird 2,2 millionen
soldat und dienen ihrem land chinas
armee wurde hochgerüstet aber sie ist
unerfahren nicht kampferprobt da kam
einer mit erfahrung helfen das macht
hunger auch noch nicht gestillt ist
russlands präsident putin immer häufiger
halten beide länder gemeinsame manöver
ab eine annäherung die den westen
verunsichert es gibt natürlich den
austausch von waffentechnologie wobei es
zunehmend so ist dass china die waffen
nach russland liefert und es ist
tatsächlich auch so dass wir schon
gemeinsame trainings einsätze in der
ostsee und im mittelmeer gesehen haben
also direkt an der grenze der nato china
weitet unaufhaltsam seinen machtbereich
aus mit dem projekt seidenstraße rückt
das land immer näher an europa heran
diesem wirtschaftlichen aufstieg folgt
die militärische absicherung chinas
vision eine globale supermacht die
entwicklung der volksbefreiungsarmee
zielt auf einen wesentlich größeren
internationalen einfluss ab china will
parallel zu seinem wirtschaftlichen
standorten in der ganzen welt seine
militärische stützpunkte erweitern
präsident ski hat einen traum für seine
nation
es ist ein traum von neuer größe von
einem chinesischen jahrhundert das ist
in der tat ein großer traum aber was hat
die nato plötzlich im westpazifik
verloren ja das weiß die nato selbst
auch noch nicht so genau im bild
gesprochen weiß sie nur dass sie dorthin
muss wie sehr die nato in sachen china
noch um eine haltung ring zeigt schon
die diskussion darüber welchen begriff
man eigentlich benutzen soll wenn man
von china redet es ist nicht feind oder
gar gegner
das wäre zu viel gesagt es ist aber auch
nicht partner oder freund deswegen hat
man sich in der abschlusserklärung jetzt
auf den begriff strategische
herausforderung geeinigt weiter
unklarheit und auch so sehr man auch im
wagen blieb sind zwei dinge klar zum
einen ist der nato klar dass schon das
allein das hochrüsten chinas zur
militärischen großmacht erzwingt dass
man sich mit china auseinandersetzt und
auch versucht china in künftige
abrüstungsverträge einzubeziehen was ja
nötig ist nach dem ende des vertrags
durch washington und moskau und zweitens
ist auch klar dass das thema großen
streitpotenzial bietet das sieht man
schon daran wie sehr die einschätzung
darüber auseinander gehen wie gefährlich
china eigentlich ist als symbol dafür
könnte man jetzt die debatte um die fünf
gehen netzwerke nehmen da halten die
amerikaner zum beispiel der europäer vor
allem die deutschen schlichtweg für viel
zu naiv und wie ist die nato überhaupt
nach diesen 30 stunden london in der
verfassung neue globale
herausforderungen zu besprechen
die nato steht jetzt zumindest wieder
als sein bündnis da was an der
oberfläche geeint ist donald trump ist
hier geradezu zum multilateralismus
engagiert angela merkel ist erleichtert
darüber dass sie mal nicht am pranger
stand dafür dass deutschland zu wenig
ins militär investiert und dem mangel
makro hat sich hier dafür gefeiert mit
seinen steilen thesen vom hirntod der
nato eine grundsatzdebatte angestoßen zu
haben aber unter dieser oberfläche
bleiben natürlich alle streitthemen
erhalten die frage wie sich die nato
strategisch für die zukunft aufstellt
wie sie mit russland umgehen soll wie
sie mit neuen bedrohungen umgehen soll
all diese grundsatzfragen sind jetzt in
die expertenkommission vertagt worden
sobald die an
fängt zu tagen ist alles wieder auf
wiedervorlage aber diesen kleinen
selbstbetrug hat man sich so kurz vor
weihnachten in london einfach mal
gegönnt dankeschön stefan und
unterdessen läuft gerade zwischen berlin
und moskau ein thriller wie aus den
tiefen des kalten krieges geht es geht
um einen auftragskiller im dienste
moskaus der mitten in berlin
zugeschlagen haben soll
dieser bedacht stand schon seit der tat
in der august im raum
und jetzt hat er sich wohl so erhärtet
dass eine diplomatische konfrontation
unvermeidlich wurde andreas kühn as
berichtet einen mordanschlag hat der
mann der gegen russland kämpfte überlebt
es war in tiflis acht kugeln vier
treffen
gorny dakar gilt als staatsfeind als
terrorist seit er gegen die russen
kämpfte erst in tschetschenien dann in
georgien ein kommandeur auf der flucht
in berlin muss er sich sicher gefühlt
haben im deutschen sommer im kleinen
park sein mörder kommt mit dem fahrrad
und schießt es dauert bis die behörden
überzeugt sind
es dauert bis heute am mittag zieht der
generalbundesanwalt die ermittlungen an
sich weil er überzeugt ist dass eine
staatliche stelle in russland den
anschlag in auftrag gab sagt er etwas
über die bedeutung
dieses verbrechens auch was den
politischen hintergrund angeht
am nachmittag trommelt das auswärtige
amt die eu botschafter zusammen der
politische direktor gibt bekannt
deutschland weist zwei mitarbeiter der
russischen botschaft aus strafe dafür
dass die russischen behörden trotz
wiederholter hochrangiger und
nachdrücklicher aufforderungen nicht
hinreichend bei der aufklärung des
mordes mitgewirkt haben
von jetzt auf gleich ist tiefe krise im
deutsch russischen verhältnis erstmal
haben dir diese maßnahme ergriffen das
wissen sie ja auch durch unsere
verlautbarung weil wir nicht gesehen
haben dass russlands und bei der
aufklärung dieses mordes unterstützt die
deutschen ermittler glauben dass der
verdächtige ein auftragskiller ist der
sonst in russland meldet eine
überwachungskamera zeigen
er kommt mit dem fahrrad und schießt nun
sollen der pass der visumantrag und die
art seiner gefälschten identität auf
staatliche hilfe hinweisen durch
stellenden russland oder tschetschenien
das zu russland gehört es gibt keinen
ernsten verdacht gegen russland denn es
kann keinen geben sagt am telefon kreml
sprecher peskow
die vermutungen sind absolut unbegründet
als vergeltung kündigt russland die
ausweisung deutscher diplomaten an eine
entwicklung die die berliner opposition
besorgt das parlament muss darüber
informiert werden und es wäre glaube ich
auch gut wenn die bundesregierung das
parlament informiert bevor man solche
gravierenden schritte selbstständig
ergreift wie gravierend wie tief die
neue krise ist wird sich bereits am
montag zeigen merkel und putin sind
verabredet um über die ukraine zu reden
bis dahin dürften die zwei russischen
botschaftsmitarbeiter bereits in
russland sein
sie haben deutschland binnen weniger
tage zu verlassen
nachrichten nun vom kaiser berichtet da
schauen wir auf die spd zwei tage vor
dem parteitag bringen sich befürworter
und gegner der großen koalition weiter
in position
so stellte josef kühnert klar er lehne
die groko weiterhin ab in einem
vorherigen interview habe er lediglich
darauf hingewiesen dass die delegierten
die folgen ihrer entscheidung durch
denken sollten
laut medienberichten wollen die
designierten parteichefs esken und
walter borjans den parteitag nicht
ausdrücklich über den fortbestand der
großen koalition abstimmen lassen
hitzewellen stürme dürren 2018 hatte
extremes wetter in deutschland so
heftige folgen wie in kaum einem anderen
land
laut dem klima-risiko-index der
umweltorganisation germanwatch waren nur
japan und die philippinen noch stärker
betroffen
so habe der damalige hitzesommer mehr
als 1200 menschen das leben gekostet und
allein bei der landwirtschaft schäden in
höhe von 700 millionen euro verursacht
die organisation wies allerdings darauf
hin dass aus vielen armen ländern
verlässliche daten fehlen betrachtet man
die vergangenen 20 jahre litten puerto
rico myanmar und hp am meisten unter
extrem wetter
der index berücksichtigt sowohl die
absoluten schadenssummen als auch ihr
verhältnis zur kaufkraft eines landes
verteidigungsministerin kramp
karrenbauer zeigt sich offen für eine
stärkere bewaffnung deutscher soldaten
in afghanistan
es fehle ihnen die möglichkeit selbst
aktiv für schutz zu sorgen sagte sie auf
dem bundeswehrstützpunkt in kundus das
lager im norden des landes war zuletzt
mehrfach beschossen worden
eine option wäre die bewaffnung einer
neuen drohne die die bundeswehr bestellt
hat bisher ohne bewaffnung mehr als 100
milliarden euro
das ist der geschäftszahlen der jedes
jahr durch cyber kriminalität entsteht
allein in deutschland um die netzwelt
sicherer zu machen wurde in darmstadt
heute ein forschungs
drum eröffnet das größte dieser art in
europa im auftrag der fraunhofer
gesellschaft der tu und der hochschule
darmstadt sollen dort mehr als 500
wissenschaftler arbeiten durch den
wirbelsturm kam uri sind auf den
philippinen mindestens 17 menschen ums
leben gekommen
außerdem gibt es vermisste und viele
verletzte der sturm hat gebäude zerstört
und bäume entwurzelt viele gebete stehen
unter wasser hunderttausende menschen
mussten sich in sicherheit bringen und
auch der schiff und flugverkehr waren
eingeschränkt
in den dramatischen tagen der auflösung
des staatsapparates ddr war es ein ganz
besonderer augenblick von
selbstbestimmung und bürgerstolz als
demonstranten nicht nur ihr eigenes
schicksal in die hand nahmen sondern
auch die instrumente des
unterdrückungsapparates als sie die
zentralen der stasi stürmten um die
dokumente dort zu sichern damit eines
tages die wahrheit offensichtlich wird
und das recht eine chance bekommt dieser
sturm auf die zentrale der berliner
normannenstraße im januar 1990 ist eine
legende geworden
aber diese legende hatte vorläufer in
den regionen in leipzig soll in rostock
und zuallererst in erfurt heute von 30
jahren dann jeweils sonntag berichtet
über die erinnerung heute und das
geschehen damals
barbara sengewald genau dort wo sie auch
vor 30 jahren stand vor der damaligen
stasi zentrale in erfurt die
revolutionäre von damals feiern heute
ihren historischen sieg
[Musik]
zum ersten mal überhaupt hatten bürger
den geheimdienst eines landes gestoppt
wo einst die stasi ihre gefangenen
festhielt ist heute die gedenkstätte
andreasstraße und barbara sengewald
leben teil der ausstellung sie war eine
der ersten besetzerinnen und die alten
männer die und dann also auch gegenüber
saßen und uns rede und antwort stehen
sollten
also ich hab da überhaupt keinen respekt
oder irgendwie sowas gehabt ich habe so
gedacht von solchen leuten haben wir uns
nun derartig bestimmen lassen und solche
angst gehabt
die mauer ist längst gefallen im
dezember 89 aber die stasi macht einfach
weiter und verbrennt akten im großen
stil sichtbar steigt der rauch über
erfurt aufschluss damit hunderte
menschen zusammen getrommelt von einer
gruppe von frauen fordern einlass auch
tele büchner ist dabei als die menge die
letzte bastion der sed-herrschaft
übernimmt ab jetzt kontrollieren die
bürger die stasi
sie mussten ihre aktentaschen zeigen und
zeigen und nachweisen dass sie nichts
mit raus schleppen was eigentlich dort
verbleibt was nämlich uns gehört und wir
wollten darüber entscheiden was nun
weiter wird mit den akten und die
erfurter informieren gleich im netzwerk
besetzen versiegeln bürgerwache
aufstellen erfurt wird zum vorbild für
viele andere städte wie auch berlin
hier wird sechs wochen später die
hauptzentrale der stasi gestürmt und es
entlädt sich eine menge wut über die
spitzel akten
deswegen sind sie mehr als nur dokumente
zur aufklärung sondern sie sind eine
kooperation dies gilt hochzuhalten und
sichtbar sein auch für die nächste
generation roland jahren ist der letzte
stasi unterlagen beauftragte die akten
sollen teil des bundesarchivs werden
es geht darum kompetenz und technik zu
bündeln und wir sind teil des
gedächtnisses destinationen so können
wir diese akten zukunftssicher machen
wir können die nutzung zeitgemäß
organisieren und wir können sie ja
dauerhaft erhalten nicht alle ehemaligen
bürgerrechtler teilen dass mancher
befürchtet der zugang würde so
schwieriger für die stasi besetzerinnen
aus erfurt aber ist vor allem wichtig
dass ihre geschichte weitererzählt wird
das vermitteln das engagement sich lohnt
und dass man durchaus auch bei dingen wo
man denkt das hat ja sowieso keinen
zweck doch etwas verändern können das
ist unser beispiel unsere feiern sie
heute dort wo die stadt die
jahrzehntelang ihre gegner einstellte
aufstehen und mut zeigen so wurden sie
zu siegern der geschichte
und nochmal nachrichten
die immobilienpreise in deutschland sind
zwischen 2008 und 2018 rasant
angestiegen und das zeigen nun auch
zahlen des statistischen bundesamtes
demnach sind eigentumswohnungen und ein
bis zweifamilienhäuser durchschnittlich
um 48 prozent teurer geworden
besonders betroffen sind die großstädte
in den sieben größten städten legten
allein zwischen 2016 und 2018 die preise
für eigentumswohnungen um 25 die preise
für ein und zweifamilienhäuser um 20
prozent traut worker so nennt man
menschen die ihre arbeitsdienste über
internet plattformen anbieten oder über
entsprechende apps wie solche micro
jobber wie sie auch heißen rechtlich
einzuordnen sind dazu hat es heute ein
gerichtsurteil gegeben
grund für uns mal auf diese immer
häufiger werdende arbeitsform zu schauen
zusammen mit frank bethmann an der
frankfurter börse zunächst einmal was
für ein urteil war das heute naja ein
kraut wörter wollte klären lassen ob
seine arbeit eine selbstständige
tätigkeit ist oder eben doch den
kriterien eines
angestelltenverhältnisses entspricht
im konkreten fall holte sich der mann
aus bayern der nicht erkannt werden
möchte seine aufträge von einer
internetplattform er wurde überwiegend
für fotos bezahlt um zu dokumentieren
wie bestimmte markenartikel
verkaufsregalen präsentiert werden als
die plattformen die zusammenarbeit
beenden wollte zog er vor gericht
die richter entschieden heute kein
festes arbeitsverhältnis die plattform
sei keine bindenden verpflichtungen mit
diesen aufträgen eingegangen die
gewerkschaften kritisieren dass massiv
weil die crowd burger so unter anderem
weder über den arbeitgeber kranken und
sozialversichert sind noch anspruch auf
mindestlohn oder lohnfortzahlung im
krankheitsfall haben
da die zahl der menschen die sich so
über das internet kleinere aufträge
besorgen und nicht mehr zu einer festen
firma gehören rasant wächst fürchten die
gewerkschaften eine aushöhlung der
arbeitnehmerrechte
der interessenverband der it wirtschaft
sieht das anders
in einer heutigen stellungnahme zu dem
urteil heißt es von bitkom kraut working
ist eine völlig neue und hoch flexible
form des arbeitens und ganso
für die beauftragenden unternehmen als
auch für die crowd worker selbst große
vorteile bieten
wer hat nun recht diese frage hört die
gerichte wohl noch weiter beschäftigen
das bundesarbeitsgericht ließ heute
revision zu dankeschön frank es könnte
der größte generalstreik seit 24 jahren
werden in frankreich sollen morgen
flugzeuge und züge ausfallen
krankenhäuser und schulen schließen
feuerwehrleute und polizisten streiken
außerdem rechnet die regierung mit
krawallen hintergrund ist die geplante
rentenreform gegen die sich die
gewerkschaften schon seit monaten wehren
denn sie fürchten dadurch massive
einschnitte basketball-profi dirk
nowitzki hat schon so manche
auszeichnung bekommen heute wurde ihm
eine besondere ehre zuteil
bundespräsident steinmeier verlieh dem
41-jährigen das bundesverdienstkreuz für
sein soziales engagement
nowitzki setzt sich vor allem für kinder
ein mit zwei stiftungen und als
unicef-botschafter und dann haben wir
noch die zahlen vom mittwoch lotto 12 13
35 45 46 48 superzahl ist die 2 die
angaben sind ohne gewähr
weitere gewinnzahlen finden sie auf
lotto punkt zdf.de und im zdf text auf
seite 55 sie kleine warnung es könnte
gleich so aussehen als wollte uns nadia
nasa einen film ans herz legen
der aus einem vergangenen erfolg eine
lukrative serie machen will
eric toledano und olivier nakash haben
seinerzeit ziemlich beste freunde
gemacht zwei grundverschiedene
außenseiter finden sich da zusammen und
die ganze welt hat in dieser
französische story etwas von sich selbst
gefunden und diesen film geliebt in
ihrem späteren heute bin ich samba traf
dann eine karrierefrau im burnout auf
ein küchenhelfer ohne papiere war auch
ein erfolg
was läge für filmemacher näher als aus
solchen zwei erfolgen eine serie von so
einer art sozialkomödie zu machen
aber der neue film alles außer
gewöhnlich
ist gar nicht so er ist vor allem
ehrlich immer noch an vielen stellen
lustig aber er nimmt das schicksal der
protagonisten so ernst dass man das mit
herz und verstand spürt es ist wieder
einmal ein notfall einer von vielen
jeden tag bruno w zur bahn polizei
gerufen sein schützling der schwer
autistischen josef hat in der u-bahn
unsinn gemacht dass tasche sagt ich habe
die notbremse gezogen aber nicht mit da
darfst du rhinow kümmert sich um
sogenannte schwerst fälle ein 24 stunden
job dafür überhaupt allein mit den
öffentlichen fan tut mir wirklich leid
versucht mich zu beißen
also das würde mich allerdings schon
sehr stark wundern er ist erst überhaupt
kein gewalttätiger typ wirklich nicht
darf ich meine mutter haben das darf er
nicht er macht macht öfter mal solche
witze josef ist einer von dutzenden
menschen die brüno mit seiner privaten
organisation hingebungsvoll betreut
menschen die so schwer autistisch sind
dass sie kein anderer aufnehmen will
keine sorge
es geht etwas ausgebremst alles was im
film erzählt wird entspricht der
realität
ich habe zur vorbereitung viel zeit in
diesen hilfseinrichtungen und mit
autistischen menschen verbracht es ist
eine erfahrung die mich völlig
überwältigt hat neuzugang in brunos
betreuungsprogramm war longo ein
besonders schwerer fall er kann nicht
sprechen neigt zu gewaltausbrüchen und
muss einen kopfschutz tragen was hab ich
gesagt
brüno bekommt bei seiner arbeit
unterstützung von seinem freund mario
maric bildet junge menschen zu klägern
für autisten aus wir uns einander
gegenüber ein betreuer ein jugendlicher
und wie machen die kleine übung die wir
schon kennen beide arbeiten am rande der
belastungsgrenze und am rand der
legalität
denn es fehlen staatliche genehmigungen
die beiden dass die inspekteure vegas
sagt ihr was die kontrollieren alle
sozialen einrichtungen die haben dich im
visier
ich habe eine lösung gefunden matteo lab
rat über aggressiv schlug er mit dem
kopf gegen die wand selbst über
medikamente steckt er immer weiter immer
weiter auch sein umfeld und er schläft
du ein zwei stunden pro nacht wird keine
einzige zugelassene einrichtung stehen
er wurde elfmal abgelehnten matthäus
kreis nehmen sie sie alle krankenhäuser
und staatliche einrichtungen wissen
nichts mit diesen menschen anzufangen
unser film soll wie ein alarmzeichen
sein und zum nachdenken anregen darüber
in welcher gesellschaft wir leben wollen
wenn wir die verletzlichsten unter uns
nicht auffangen dann ist unsere
gesellschaft ungesund brüno und malleg
gibt es wirklich
eigentlich heißen sie stefan benhamou
und david tattoo seit mehr als 20 jahren
pflegen sie mit ihren privaten vereinen
schwerbehinderte und wie im film müssen
sie ständig mit den behörden kämpfen
alles außer gewöhnlich ist ein starkes
plädoyer für die kraft der
menschlichkeit bewegend und warmherzig
mit grandiosen darstellern und ab morgen
in deutschen kinos das auslandsjournal
gleich ist zur asiatischen greta tun
werks gereist zwei jungen mädchen auf
bali die den plastikmüll der trauminsel
den kampf ansagen und das mit erfolg
bleiben sie also bitte bei uns bis
morgen
[Musik]
einen schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter der november 2019
fällt unter die wärmsten november monate
mit 2015 und 2016 in einer reihe
das sind quasi die wärmsten november und
wenn man auf europa schaut erkennt man
hier im westen europas war es zu kühl
und im osten europas zu warm und
dahinter steckt eigentlich die
wetterlage die sehr stabil war und die
warme luft immer wieder nach norden und
die kalte nach süden transportiert hat
dementsprechend hat sich hier also in
den durchschnittstemperaturen die
wetterlage quasi manifestiert stabil ist
das wetter immer noch aber zurzeit ist
es ein hoch über uns das ist die karte
von heute mittag in den nebelgebieten
war es ziemlich kalt mit minus 2 grad
sonst deutlich milder mit sieben bis
acht grad und so geht es morgen auch
weiter schauen wir in die nacht da
bereiten sich die nebel banker aus in
der mitte klart es auf und es wird
frostig kalt vor allem im süden bis
minus acht grad kalt aber der frau zieht
sich bis zur elbe hoch in schleswig
holstein sind es plus sechs grad
morgen starten wir mit nebel in den tag
und dann löst er sich teilweise auf und
die sonne kommt heraus im nordwesten ist
es dicht bewölkt aber die sonne längere
zeit scheint wird es mild sein mit
werten bis 8 grad im süden sonst unter
dem nebel 0 bis 2 grad
die nächsten tage am freitag wird es von
nordwesten her allmählich nasser und
sturm über der nordsee zwei bis neun
grad
ja und das wochenende das wird ebenfalls
nass und windig weiter gehen die
temperaturen bei 4 bis 10 grad
damit ein schöner abend